hey guys it is the 14th of December my
name is just and here's the things that
are happening in gaming news plus up
Bethesda has revealed a release date and
details for the upcoming dishonor to
update the update is set to arrive on
December 19 for xbox one ps4 and PC
although the beta version is already
available for PC players it introduces
the long-awaited new game plus mode
which allows players to use both Emily
and corvo's abilities in a single
playthrough but des der explained new
game plus lets you begin anew as I the
character with access to each
character's full suite of abilities plus
all the bone charm traits and runes
collected from your previous play
through that you can reassign to choose
the powers you want the publisher added
that more options to customize the
gameplay experience will be arriving in
January including a mission select
option and a custom difficulty setting
game director Harvey Smith also
commented on the performance issues with
the pc version of Dishonored 2 saying
there were certain combinations of
things that we just didn't expect
despite extensively testing the game
very high in CPUs with low-end GPUs and
all the drivers things like that I'm a
PC gamer there's nothing like running on
a super high-end PC but it's also the
most varied platform to support its way
way more complicated than consoles next
up uncharted force free survival update
has arrived and here's what's news the
three point eight gigabyte update
introduces the new co-op who would like
survival mode two new multiplayer maps
of five new weapons and classic
uncharted two and three music has been
added to menus and ingame there are also
dozens of new character skins vanity
items and color options plus a boosted
level cap 290 12 new corp trophies and
10th wants to really stick it to your
foes the update also changes up the
economy by reducing the prices of vanity
DLC chests and gameplay DL feature and
it applies a whole bunch of balance and
bug fixes you can check out the full
patch notes in a story on games but
finally the latest call of duty modern
warfare remastered update has introduced
microtransactions supply drops have
returned which are random loot drops
first introduced in Call of Duty
advanced warfare
this can be purchased with Depot credits
which can be earned in game or bought
with call of duty points that you can
purchase using real money these supply
drops only contain cosmetic items and
the same items can all be earned by
completing in-game challenges if you
aren't keen on forking out real world
dollars you can also purchase a bunch of
new melee weapons like a shovel or a
hammer the same update that brought in
said microtransactions also delivered
female fighters are six more maps and
two new game modes gun game and hard
point that is all I've got for you today
do head to gamespot for our best games
of the year by platform and I will see
you again tomorrow